so we have several speakers today
that are principal investigators from
idea states
they are going to discuss today a bit
about the research projects at nappy
some expectations and outcomes
how researchers are using data to
embrace collaboration and answer
questions faster and how initiatives
like strides are helping to democratize
research funding
so i think i will
give it over to you
um
ellia if you are ready
yes uh thank you laura so again we have
here with us dr gus kusulis he's the
president of nepe
mr jesus gomez who's the strategic
business executive for google cloud
dr nicole garrison she's the assistant
professor at west virginia in bre
dr luis quinones uh who is the
co-director of puerto rico from inbury
and i don't see
um
dr judy crabtree who was going to be
here as well
but the main question is uh as i
understand uh nepea as a network is
trying to solve a problem that is common
across the network uh inbreeze and uh
you know the major challenge is
uh as we just heard from nicole and from
louise
how do you actually make this accessible
to a lot of students
how do you combine bioinformatics and
data science training in
non-bioinformatics and data science
training curriculum
how do you help
students
use bioinformatics and research projects
and then how do you actually move from
education to
careers you know what do they do after
this so maybe because you can start by
kind of sharing what is your vision how
do you address this common need across
the network
yeah sure uh so first of all i'm happy
to
participate in this panel i'm also the
principal investigator of the louisiana
biomedical research network on lbrn
uh so in that capacity um i could speak
also to that in addition to nepy but i
think um
you know one of the big challenges that
we all face is that um
azo correctly i think nicole
mentioned this fear
of computer science bioinformatics
how people get into it
we have a lot of people from biology
that would love to use tools and we have
computer scientists that don't
understand the biology so you know
bridging that gap between those two
disciplines becomes very important
and
frankly the only way i see that
uh obviously uh our 23 states and puerto
rico are doing
their own uh efforts within each state
there's a lot of resources a lot of
manpower a lot of talent
that's devoted in each state
we are through nappy we haven't seen
maybe as much networking and commonality
allow resources to be shared by others
understand best practices what works
what doesn't work there may be some
specificity to its program but maybe
there are some common things that we
could focus on and what we hope through
napie is to make available
everything that everybody has that could
be shared freely could be made available
including their personal stories right
interviews uh what nicole just talked
about or our puerto rican colleague
mentioned
what works you know what what's the
personal story how
certain students have been approached
and and i think through
examples i think everybody else can
learn
uh to adopt some of these because some
of them may be specific to our own
states and institutions some of them may
be common but i think what nep is trying
to achieve is becoming a medium of
communicating
across the board of all these stories
and successes and see what could be
common um my own
you know how do you transform things
right uh
within lsu at least
we have sort of decided that the only
way to do this
is to really
promote new
degrees
you know try to get an undergraduate
degree
in
data science and bioinformatics
something that
commits people
into taking
specific courses and graduating specific
credentials
we've tried the certificate issue the
training issue but it's always within
primary the graduate institutions and my
colleagues could
you know comment on this
it's always typically very hard to get a
student to participate in something
that's extracurricular or certificate
because they really the primary interest
is to graduate and get a degree in
something so unless you have a a degree
program
that really focuses you know on data
science and and overall and perhaps by
phobatics specifically or how data
science plays into bioinformatics or the
other way around you know you wouldn't
have probably the impact um
so one of the ideas here at louisiana is
to
try to
promote within puis
the creation of um
bachelors of science either as a
[Music]
major or a minor
depending what the universities is and
then at that level throughout louisiana
inbrief lbrn try to help them
teach that maybe through free content
through things that we could provide
other through um
you know uh
freely available tools through
collaboration with find that tech or
whatever we can
uh it's a difficult issue because
as you know probably most of you
changing curriculum from you know
promoting a new course it's
it's a very slow process at least here
in louisiana but uh um
we at lsu are trying now to create a an
undergraduate degree
and hopefully a master's degree there's
a master's degree already offered in new
orleans it hasn't really
[Music]
been launched yet we hope that make it
available
across the institutions in louisiana but
unless we really somehow put this into
the undergraduate curriculum at least as
a minor i don't think when i had the
impact uh you know and i'll stop there
and let my colleagues chime in
yeah
luis i know that you've thought about
this
yourself as well
what is your thought about this
i agree with dr casullas that we have to
share our common efforts
um to the inbre webpages and to the navy
web pages
so everyone can have access around
around the nation
so um if i can provide something that
can be useful
to louisiana or to virginia
it will be um
it will be a great pleasure
so um i prefer the stuff not just for me
i i want to share it with everyone
around the island and that is what i'm
doing right now and starting toward that
path to share everyone everything that i
got
with everyone but in that sense i have
to give the training so i am creating
right now a critical mass
with um people with interest in
bioinformatics so they can start
teaching this stuff
in their courses so
people that wants to belong to the
community of practice is is a voluntary
step
but people don't know want to
participate on this initiative will
receive the impact and the training
because teaching faculty are going to
include this stuff in their courses so
across um biology
they will teach this love and
no
students will escape
at least receiving some kind of
knowledge and training
so they will be prepared to face
i mean the requirements after they exit
our programs
nicole did you want to add to that
yeah i mean i to kind of
re-emphasize i
that's true um we we should be sharing
um i think that
part of the problem is
not that there aren't resources but that
they're not organized in a way that
students can
really access and so it is important to
get the faculty to incorporate these
lessons into their curriculum
so one thing i've been trying to do
and people are very willing to let me do
this is do guest lectures
for a particular topic that is more
bioinformatically oriented
even if it's very basic just introducing
the students to me as a professor and to
the topic
seems to be very helpful and then they
start asking questions about like where
can i learn more of this if i take this
class will i get more of this kind of
stuff
because they just really don't even
realize what bioinformatics is
so i think that really does help to get
other professors in non-bioinformatic
courses teaching some of this type of
material
so so with us we have jesus who
hasn't had the chance to introduce
himself yet so i hope that he does this
uh now uh but also you know i hope this
is you can put aside kind of your
professional role for a second as a you
know a person who has maybe a product a
solution uh and think of this as you
know uh this is this program this idea
program um uh targets a very specific
audience that has unique needs um and
special kinds of uh objectives uh so
just as a company uh you know as someone
that has
that industry perspective
um how do you view this perspective
maybe starting from an introduction of
who you are and what you're you know
here to represent and then into that
problem that we're discussing
yeah sure um can you hear me
yes okay perfect
my name is jesus gomez i am part of the
strategy and innovation group
uh within google and i am responsible
for the solutions in education academic
research
i have been in google over
five years almost six and have worked
with many research groups on
bioinformatics across universities
biobanks
the broad institute etc
and
i have been also engaged on the
strides program we were the foundational
member
first participated uh member of of the
strike program so
one of the things that we keep hearing
from the bioinformatics that is very
aligned to your comments is
when you ask researchers um for example
this is just an example how much time
do they spend in trying to reproduce
results
sometimes they say that 30
of that time is just trying to reproduce
results so imagine that you have a grant
where
you have to apply personal medicine
pipeline and you work with another
institution that institution has to
provide results you have to validate
that result
you are spending you get the pipeline
from then you spend 30 of your time
maybe even thirty percent of your grant
in trying to reproduce that result
and that's a challenge right
um so one of the things that we are
doing from the technology perspective is
we're doing two things working with nih
and
and the rest of partners here one is
technology development it's how
much you can abstract researchers from
the complexity of technology so that
they can focus on a science as much as
possible okay so if you run a pipeline
in a university
and you're running another university
tomorrow you should get the same result
easily
that's one of the things that we're
doing the other thing that we are doing
is we are working with strides
to create personalized training
okay where we say like okay this is for
bioinformatics this is for medical
imaging this is for
interoperability healthcare data
and that's to your point that could be
this type of training that is
created between the industry and
academic can be great to be incorporated
in the curriculum in the new programs
that you are launching in university
type of transversal skills you know
there are some basic transversal skills
that will apply to everyone
those are training that are funded by
nih that you can leverage nih is being
allocated that budget they send people
to your university to train on that
to use this tool to know how to use this
tool and then you on the top
you add your own curriculum content your
science
knowledge right and i think if we can do
that
we can help the community
to actually get much more
uh
out of the grant
and much faster right i think
uh we are at that point where we are at
the intersection of technology and
science
and sometimes we have the problem that
we
are making too difficult
for great great scientists to use
technologies you know they don't have to
become experienced technology they have
to use the tools and our job is how
easily you can
make them to use this tool so that they
can focus on science
thank you but you know i think for all
of us uh that brings us to the next
question the question is funding right
so
a lot of uh the efforts that are being
described here funded through nih grants
you know the center grants et cetera so
uh gus you know as somebody who's
managed and received
millions of dollars in grant funding um
how do you see a more effective use of
that funding to incorporate such
training you know introduction to
different tools you know these are tools
that perhaps are not very cheap like
google cloud you know how do you see
that just from a funding perspective
well um
obviously
uh
the funding that's provided by nih or
other resources is fairly limited um
and typically is driven by large
programs that are funded on a
competitive basis that unfortunately for
us
uh sort of
excludes or doesn't focus on the idea
states and
one of the basic principles of energy ms
at this point
is that in order to have the country be
competitive
all states have to participate and be
elevated so i think it's a
responsibility not only of the federal
government but also companies like
google amazon ibm
to really focus and provide resources to
those 24 states
because that's basically where they
perhaps even the biggest impact could be
achieved in terms of you know manpower
development
um so um
i would definitely
try to
attract a
uh institutional private uh public
partnerships
to create an environment where it's
conducive to
be transformative
and you know i would turn the table to
uh
our google representative jesus and
asked him the question
if google was to
think
of an undergraduate curriculum
that focuses on data science and
bioinformatics you know what would it be
um because you know the perspective is
different right you know in the
university setting
we're teaching biology we're teaching
you know a lot of molecular biology and
sort of by the way
you first asked the question and now
then you go about finding
how to answer uh the question and one of
the approaches could be to use a
biopharmatic tool
a lot of the other approaches is more
wet lab based that a lot of people
concentrate but we're at the point that
they're reversing happening where
basically through systems biology a lot
of the questions could be posed there
are totally different questions that you
would ask from the biology perspective
so and i think sitting
in companies like google or amazon and
so on
i suspect their perspective is very
different so i don't know uh jesus
whether um
google has been thinking what would it
be the ideal curriculum
for a an undergraduate degree in data
science slash
bioinformatics that's a great question
so
and um this is something that we keep
refining based on things that we
have from you right because you are the
ones that actually
knows all the challenges and how we can
overcome there are two things that we
are trying to do
as an example in our side
the first thing is
for students for example we give
all the consumption is free
any students
globally
can access our tool for a
teaching and learning practice at the
school at no cost
okay that's the first thing that we do
like
everyone that is curious to use this
tool
should be able to use it even if they
cannot afford it
and that's we have our credit program
at the same time
we have created free training that is
available in internet that you can
incorporate
in your program for example joe
hawking's medicine school is using our
free training as part of the curriculum
you could include that as well
with basic skills that we think
are very important for the
undergraduate
students so that they can start asking
the right question about the data
okay and i will give you an example
all the
nih reference data sets are
on cloud through strides
any student can access gcga
dba gen 3 data
the public data set
and can't run analysis with these tools
at no cost and one of the things that
you can check for example is getting
people that has
a varying is specific genomic and
compared with
the reference data set on the average
people and you can start seeing the
difference then you can pick on certain
genomes start seeing the difference so
what we are trying to do is like how
easy we can do
to encourage that curiosity of the
student
right
then there is
one gap that is the most difficult one
is that yeah we can create that content
we can give access to the technology
but behind that context is the science
knowledge and this is something that we
will never be able to do to to
um
replace this is where you need your
programs right you need to make sure
that you can connect the students
with these tools
and you help them to reason and to find
this answer by themselves right so i
think in our case what we are trying to
do is just
helping your students to be able to
answer
bigger questions much faster
okay um but then
that is the challenge of why you need a
program right i i think is is not a
challenge it's a reality you need a
science program to be able to ask the
right questions
yeah i would let my colleagues also
chime in but um you know and you don't
have to answer this right now but i'll
post this question you know with google
and your under your leadership
uh would be willing to partner with
nappy and the idea program in creating
the idea curriculum
for
us
actually yes this is something that we
can do
um
we have people in our team that sit with
your professor
and your professor say i'm teaching this
and this and say okay so in this section
this tutorial is relevant
and it helps you to map the menu to what
you are teaching
and that's something that we can do for
you okay so
we
there is a challenge we all need this
type of skills
and to your point we'll need to make
sure that this gets out of all the
institutions
you know i'm telling you i got my degree
in spain
in spring nobody has access to large
data centers
nobody has access to tools
i
had a challenge
right now we had the possibility to
get rid of that challenge to everyone so
everyone has the same access to the same
tools
and this is something that we take it
really seriously
and we have resources for that so if you
are looking into incorporated it's a
kind of tool in your program that is
exactly what we have created these tools
and we are happy to collaborate with you
because for us to be better as a society
we need to develop skills in all type of
researchers everywhere
yeah
thank you
we're going to address you for the nice
brief meeting in october
so maybe just to give also an
opportunity to lose and nicole added to
this i mean what do you think is the
role of nepy i know that nepea exists in
part to kind of connect all of these
different efforts not only just to
connect them but also to see funding
right so um i mean uh nicole luis
who wants to add to this discussion
about you know funding challenge so i
need to correct you um if i may we're
not not-for-profit institutions so we
don't have lobbying authority but you
know we are promoting networking to make
people competitive
right exactly yeah in that sense
do you want to go first dr garrison or
do i go first
go for it
okay
i think that i have seen navy in action
during the
[Music]
last year southeast um a
regional conference
and um
they brought a lot of information share
a lot of information with us
and
spread the word among the participants
so i think that nappy performs uh
a vital role
uh in the inbred programs and is is a
way to unite on all of us
um
to increase the diversity and receive
more information of the opportunities
that are out there for us
so i think that
um the collaboration with navy and
google will be a hit
that would be fantastic i mean uh
we would love to do it um we even have
just to give you an idea we even have
worked with nsf and nih to create a
separate budget just for minority
institutions
okay
um and
just to give you an idea of how we help
we help into into a two unfunded
researchers to students i already say
right
we help you to incorporate in the
curriculum they have free access
to the tools
even for postgraduates and principal
investigators
we have programs that give them credit
so that they can use this tool to come
up with very competitive grant proposals
for free at no cost
okay
and once they receive
the grant
we
uh
we have just launched the last year
the possibility that is a flat fee
so that you can use this tool
whether you run one time the simulation
and you're running one million times
you will never
exceed your budget
this is something that we are doing
because we understand
that you have to be able to attract
good researchers and these good
researchers need to understand that if
they join your university they can win
grants
and for that we have to bring this type
of tools and programs so
we continually listen so we would love
to partner with you
apply the existing program that we have
and and if we have to tweak it for some
reason
let's tweak it because it's
if it's good for the community
that's our mission right
that's great yep
nicole did you want to add anything to
that or
i'm going to be honest i don't know that
i have much to add i'm actually learning
a lot about the connections between all
of these different programs
coming from
being outside of the inbree system i'm
still learning uh
how everybody is connected and how we're
working together so
i think it seems like
the connections are
very valuable and the knowledge of how
those all work together all these
different programs and how google might
contribute
is important for someone in my position
who is the connection between the
students and these bigger programs
because inbrie and nepy and like these
don't mean anything to our students
they are concerned with how am i going
to learn this skill and how am i going
to pass this class
but if we can show them hey here are the
resources they don't really care where
it comes from as long as they know how
to access it and what it's used for i
think um that would be beneficial to
them so
i'm going to take what i learned here
and and try and make more connections
myself
we have been monitoring a community
student
in the last two years
this
um
for example healthcare hackathons
has been
uh
the the engagement level of all the
users has been impressive and we have
been monitoring on the background
and we are member of of the hackathon
event and we see that
companies like pfizer gsk
are being part of those hackathons as
well and and you will be surprised on
how
once you create with a small effort that
community that community is
self-organized many times you know where
you were mentioning before
i think that the
the challenge is
as a group you have to decide what is
the right
organization so that people can find
things easily
but once you create that people start
sharing pipeline best practices
you know um there are for example
companies that say like hey i need i
have this problem
this is the topic of the hackathon
and there are
groups from students from many programs
that are heavily engaging because it's
also the possibility to
get visibility and get a good job
and and
i would say don't underestimate the
power of the community
because it's really important and and
you know there are a lot of people that
volunteer and do a good job managing
managing that
and you know that's actually a great
point um and we have been thinking in
epi to actually be able to do what i
call active participation as opposed to
passive um so we need to think about
hackathons or health
related things that would be across the
board you know because you know we could
list the information and it's sort of in
a passive way somebody can go in there
and look at it but to actually engage
and and encourage
young uh you know students uh
and and really engage them in a
meaningful way you need something active
something that they can really work on
and the question is what is this
maybe a hackathon would be type of
activity it could be something else a
problem posted and frankly personally i
see the involvement
of industry as a major component to that
uh not only for getting philanthropic
funding that the thing is needed but
even beyond that to connect
really the academic world with the
industrial world because ultimately our
graduates would be you know your
employees all in the long run and
elsewhere and they will contribute uh
you know in the in terms of economic
development in multiple sectors so
that's what we're trying to do with
nippy we kind of restarted built a new
website we're trying to
get some automated systems in
it will take some time to get to that
level hopefully at the nisbri uh meeting
in october we'll be able to launch some
of these new activities and invite
participants um it would be
a process right
and at some point i'd love to see a uh
an undergraduate degree here in
louisiana taught in
20 undergraduate institutions with
listed in all their curricula but really
taught by multiple faculty that are
really dispersed
you know within the state that could be
replicated in west virginia could be
replicated somewhere else and who knows
maybe at some point it would be
an idea undergraduate degree you know
that's actually uniform across the
network uh but i mean that's basically
the
long-term vision
uh and i think
and i've seen this because i've been for
many years in academia
um you see some young minds that get
exposed and they blossom and they become
extremely good
but you have to provide an opportunity
because if they don't see it
they don't get to interact they don't
get the right mentorship early on they
actually lost they end up in some other
field you know that that really they
could have done much better elsewhere so
really mentoring and reaching as early
as possible becomes very important
i just want to add to that we had
another speaker earlier today from the
pistoia alliance
the pistol alliance brings together all
the major pharmaceutical companies
and they have somehow figured out a way
to partner on pre-competitive challenges
that all of them face
and i think that this is somewhat
similar to what we're trying to you know
discuss here because
um everybody has their interests
everybody's got their objectives but in
in some areas like training and like uh
you know encouraging students to pursue
certain topics this is a field where
everybody can agree to work together and
find a meaningful way to get that and i
think the hackathon idea actually is
really great
i'll use this opportunity to say that
you mentioned that the nisberry meeting
is in october right guys right
this meeting information will be posted
on the netbi website uh very soon
and once it is and we'll of course send
it out to everybody who's participated
in this meeting as well
maybe this is the time to start planning
because you know hackathons even though
they seem like just the time to get
together and do something you know in
reality they take a lot of planning for
people to be prepared identifying topics
all of these things
so
this is definitely a great idea
uh jesus do you wanted to add something
to that
yeah um i have an idea for that um
let's get for example the state of
louisiana right you talk to your hhs
department
and you ask the like what is more
important for you
they're going to tell you maybe tobacco
research
maybe cancer research
we can do that the topic of the
hackathon okay we get that public data
set
of data luciana research
and we ask a question to the
participants and then all the schools
agree
that the students participating are
gonna go into
their contest and you are gonna give
them a grade and an assignment based on
the position on the hackathon
i commit to give the credits so that
everyone can run the tool for free
and we will have somebody to we will
share training on the tools in advance
and we can even
try to have somebody on site to help
them
talk with you fantastic ideas
happening yeah estate is happy as
schools start collaborating as students
are engaged
we give it a try let's see what happened
yeah and we can replicate that later and
we could work with elia and see how what
we could fit something and that
right now in
louisiana cancer is number one target
obviously because
uh there's a lot of effort and we if you
look at heat maps you know of course if
you look at even at uh
across the board on idea states you know
cancer obesity
diabetes
poverty is our common you know
difficulties
so
cancer is number one interesting enough
because we're now cannabis
producers they have cannabis related
drugs
and therapeutics but also
a target
for across the state but i'm not sure
what kind of a topic could be mined
out of that i've been told there are 180
uh
drugs uh chemicals that actually use all
sorts of purposes and the question is
how could they be applied and what kind
of you know
data mining it really is available and
needed after that but uh just
parenthetically i'm mentioning these two
targets uh of course we are
big on infectious diseases we have um in
essence three primate centers
the tulane national prime center i'm
chairing the external advisory committee
there
we have the uh
chimp sanctuary in shreveport and the
new iberia private center
um uh
and so infectious diseases including
um obviously kobe 19 and everything else
um from west nile to dengue to chinga
cunha and other viruses also become very
important but you know are all sorts of
interesting topics i think cancer may be
an overall topic that really will
revibrate across all our idea states and
that's a big one as you know um
president biden is pushing rph which is
the program the federal program let me
add 5 billion to nahs that would be
targeted for cancer research
the state of louisiana has set as
priority one cancer research our new
president tate that came from usc
uh south carolina has cancer's priority
number one interesting now data science
and mathematics is a priority number two
for lsu right now so i'm pleased to
actually see that uh you know uh
directed from the president um so yeah
that would be fantastic so we can work
on that and we could revisit this issue
with uh you know with google and you
know fine butt deck and see what can be
done
so briefly before everyone else leaves
because we're kind of running over time
i did want to mention laura here
who has been doing a wonderful job
throughout the symposium to coordinate
everybody's talks and introduce everyone
uh she's going to be around to uh be
involved in this project so
hopefully over the the course of the
next few months i will be able to be in
contact with all of the inbree programs
related to bioinformatics data science
we've got the contacts at google
who have been participating here and
presenting their tools and we'll try to
really involve as many people as
possible and maybe that's that's one of
the first things like you mentioned you
know what is that major topic that
everybody can agree on uh that students
will be interested in companies will be
interested in uh faculty will be
interested in uh you know maybe in terms
of funding priorities also you know what
is the top funding priority to to give
them a motivation
and i think on a heck of a thing even
nih could be interested or through
supplemental funding uh especially you
know google or anybody else would be
interested so um if we could do
something in the context of nisbri it
would be great because you know
normally we get up to a thousand
participants because this is virtual
it's possible that we go to 1500 or
higher on
the first week of october
there will be a lot of people including
uh
you know administrative
political and other entities listening
in so i think this is the time where a
network could really push forward uh for
the next uh
sort of transformational steps uh
because we kind of um if i may we kind
of wobble around we're doing different
things we're doing a great job locally
but we don't have uh
orders of magnitude right we haven't
really
harnessed the power of those 23 states
in puerto rico you know working together
we do represent half of the country
maybe even more than half of the
population and a lot of resources so
people have to listen to us and we need
all the assistance that we we uh we
deserve and that to really be able to
fulfill
um you know
participating you know in our success as
we have demonstrated really by
graduating nationally competitive
investigators uh that come from the idea
state uh i only gonna leave you the last
note of from the point of view nepy
the idea states that the net exporters
are talent to everybody else right so
our undergrad students graduated in
sports tax and faculty
get extremely successful and
unfortunately for us a lot of them moved
to you know mit harvard
texas and elsewhere which is i think a
success but ultimately i think we need
to create
circumstances we can develop these
resources
where they originate
all right well thank you everyone again
for participating we have a plan of
action uh great contribution from
everyone who joined and from all the
speakers so thank you again uh we will
be following up and being in touch again
uh laura i wanted her to be on here and
for everyone to connect the dots and and
really be in touch so thank you again
uh jesus for joining and supporting this
idea uh really uh good to have you with
us
and thank you for having us
and thank you for what you do for your
community it's awesome and thank you eli
laura you've done a great job that's
wonderful to actually listening on and
off throughout these couple days great
job
thank you thank you for coming and
speaking as well to all of you
all right thank you everyone and thank
you luis
again for joining and for sharing today
and nicole garrison uh thank you
and guess it's always a pleasure to see
and hear your insights about all this
all right take care